ha hablado ya boris johnson y qué
perspectivas se le presenta al primer
ministro de cara al debate del jueves
buenas tardes el voto del jueves era
importante pero especialmente
significativo para crear un precedente
dado que el gobierno mantiene las
mayorías en la cámara de los comunes así
que este voto que se busca para que el
parlamento un comité especial investigue
si el primer ministro le mintió o no al
parlamento sobre el partido
podría o no avanzar entretanto el primer
ministro ha pedido disculpas ha dicho
que lo siente que este comportamiento no
se repetirá pero ha dejado claro que no
dará un paso al costado entre tanto los
partidos de oposición han dicho que es
claro que boris johnson no solamente le
metió al parlamento sino también al
público y por ello debe dar un paso al
costado está en el malestar en el
parlamento que hemos visto en la
comparecencia de esta tarde que el jefe
del partido laborista de oposición ha
llamado a johnson deshonesto
sinvergüenza y que no respeta las
instituciones el speaker el presidente
de la cámara de los comunes le ha pedido
a decir que estarme quien modere su
lenguaje en referencia a johnson johnson
durante este debate ha permanecido
cabizbajo y en pocas oportunidades ha
levantado la cabeza para mirar a sus
interlocutores su futuro por ahora
permanece en manos de su partido el
conservador que sigue manteniendo su
confianza en su líder pero lo cierto es
que este panorama podría cambiar en las
elecciones de regionales del 6 de mayo
si los resultados no son satisfactorios
para el partido conservador
entonces podría convocarse a una moción
de censura este debate también hoy en el
parlamento ha servido para que el primer
ministro actualice a la cámara de los
comunes sobre el apoyo que el reino
unido- le está dando a ucrania como
además se han entregado armas y
millonarios recursos al presidente
selenski en esta guerra contra rusia y
también ha habido críticas feroces por
la nueva política del gobierno de enviar
a ruanda a todas las personas jóvenes
hombres especialmente que lleguen
reino unido a través del canal de la
mancha mientras se tramita su
posibilidad de estar así lados aquí en
el reino unido